[Musique]
bonjour les candidats se racontent
beaucoup en ce moment
françois mitterrand êtes vous prêt à
faire de même pas exactement
pas exactement parce que si je pense que
la vie privée vie personnelle explique
pour beaucoup la vie publique et qu'il y
a des liens très direct entre cette vie
publique et celle du privé
il m'arrive un peu de répugné à
l'exhibition mais enfin j'admets qu'il
puisse y avoir sur ce plan des
explications à donner cette réserve mise
à part il ya bien entendu des temps
forts dans votre vie privée dans votre
vie politique qui ont marqué des choix
quels sont ils plus sûrement sûrement et
malgré le peu de temps dont je dispose
je vais essayer de vous le dire
brièvement
d'abord il faut le dire un milieu
familial l'enfance mon père était du
berry ma mère et de saintonge et comme
cela se fait beaucoup dans la vie
provinciale
j'ai vécu dans la famille de ma mère mes
parents étaient très unie et nous étions
nombreux vie frères et soeurs et deux
cousins germains dont le père avait été
tué la guerre de 14 18 on leur vivait en
groupe du façon très autonome et en même
temps dans une grande liberté d'esprit
mais nous étions une famille cela dominé
je crois le reste de ma vie
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui encore nous
sommes neuf vivant nous nous voyons
beaucoup la solidarité familiale
je crois que ça compte beaucoup vous
retrouverez bien que vous soyez pas tous
à paris enfin vous êtes en une el police
percés paris a fait dans cette famille
comme fait pour tout le reste c'est dur
on était un peu aspiré vers la enfin il
y en a qui sont encore en province en
particulier en charente
ensuite il ya eu la captivité et la
résistance très important pour moi
la guerre 20 ans 21 ans il faut imaginer
1939-1940 je suis blessé et fait
prisonnier pierre sur mon lit d'hôpital
on me transporte comme tous les autres
en allemagne et je me retrouve dans un
camp en thuringe
dire au centre de l'allemagne dans la
région de vanni marc là sur un flanc de
colline
trente cinq mille hommes quelle
expérience que ce que je sais de la vie
ma famille et d'universités milieu
protégé et me voici soudain affrontés à
la vie la loi de l'effort il fallait
surmonter tout ça ce n'était pas facile
à côté de cela naturellement les amitiés
figurez vous qu aujourd'hui encore mais
mes vrais amis mais solide z'amis ce que
je revois tout moment c'est mes anciens
camarades de captivité et ils le savent
bien
n'inventons rien c'est quand même pas le
paradis est d'une certaine manière il
fallait beaucoup de solidarité pour
dominer nous étions en 1940-1941
l'allemagne de hitler cette espèce
d'europe que nous dessiner pour milan
bref j'avais envie d'en sortir
je me suis évadé j'ai voulu ma liberté
et ceux conquis une fois échec 22 jours
22 nuit à travers l'allemagne à pied
j'étais appris à la frontière suisse
le dernier soir on recommence huit mois
après je me fais reprendre à metz
quelques kilomètres de la frontière
puisqu'il avait annexion à l'époque
enfin la troisième fois était la bonne
bref j'ai conquis ma liberté j'en suis
assez fier encore aujourd'hui et j'y
tiens cette liberté la résistance
résistance a compté forcément qu'ajoute
reste particulier sinon que revenus en
france
je suis parti quelques temps plus tard
je suis revenu 20 41 j'ai organisé un
mouvement de résistance des années de
guerre au mois de mai 1942 et j'ai été
appelé à me rendre à londres et en
algérie au mois de novembre 1943 et j'ai
été reçu par le général de gaulle au
mois de décembre 1943
je suis revenu en france occupée en
février 1944 et j'ai fait partie du
premier gouvernement de la france
libérée sous l'autorité du général de
gaulle en tant que secrétaire général
provisoire aux prisonniers et rio
déportés grande expérience mais elle n'a
pas ceci d'original que j'ai retiré de
ma vie dans les camps et puis quand on
vous connaît bien on sait
rattachement pour votre département la
nièvre c'est là que vous vous replonger
en quelque sorte dans la réalité des
choses et bien j'y suis depuis 1946 ça
fait maintenant bientôt 27 ans que je
suis député de la nièvre avec un
accident en 1958
j'avais pris position par un non
catégorique à certaines formes de
régimes et aux coups d'état militaires
j'étais absent du parlement trois mois
puisque les nivernais m'ont renvoyé à ce
moment là au sénat bon alors eu en 27
ans la prends beaucoup de choses et il
est très important que vous sachiez et
au delà devons tous ceux qui veulent
bien nous écouter que j ai appris
troisième expérience c'est à dire le
travail des hommes la peine des hommes
mais aussi les situations de classe
château chinon il faut te savoir que
c'est une toute petite ville 3000
habitants mais c'est une petite capitale
aussi et c'est une ville ouvrière dans
un environnement paysans rural j'ai donc
pu confronter les deux mentalités étant
bien entendu que sa forme tout alors j
ai appris beaucoup de choses mais le
travail et la difficulté est qu'on me
permette de le dire ce n'est pas un
propos électorale ils le savent bien
une profonde affection des liens enfin
c'est comme un mariage entre nous 26 ans
et un bail
il nous reste deux minutes trente
j'aimerais me transformer en
fonctionnaires d'état civil et vous
demander des renseignements sur votre
famille tout banalement officier d'état
civil des fois vous changer de rôle et
bien voilà je suis marié depuis 30 ans
presque trente ans c'était en octobre
c'est à dire c'était encore la guerre et
j'épouse est une jeune fille que j'ai
connue elle était infirmière dans un
maquis elle avait la croix de guerre 17
ans on s'est mariés nous avons eu trois
enfants nous en avons deux aujourd'hui
deux garçons ils ont 27 et 25 ans
nous vivons tous ensemble il n'y a pas
de conflit de générations chez moi
[Musique]